wherever you go your phone goes and
inside your phone is a wealth of
personal data so what if an app tracked
your smartphone to slow the spread of
kovat 19 more than a dozen such apps are
in development across Europe apps that
might warn you to keep your distance
from others will tell you if you've been
in contact with someone who has the
virus Parliament is looking at the
potential use of such apps in their
compliance with existing EU data
protection and privacy rules the
situation is unprecedented in every
possible way
exposing a challenge even challenging
the resilience of the constitutional
dispensation of surviving Member State
this is our duty to remind that European
law is in place the European Commission
has published guidelines on kovat 19
tracking apps they need to meet certain
tests when it comes to personal data
there you should be voluntary approved
by a National Health Authority data
should be encrypted and therefore
anonymous and the use of such an app
should end as soon as it's no longer
needed the European Parliament is a
long-standing defender of personal data
it welcomes the Commission's guidelines
and will continue to protect the
fundamental rights and liberties of
Europeans especially during the corona
virus pandemic
[Music]